I don't know what to do with myself if
I'm not a mom ahead of Lisa Marie
Presley's public Memorial
ETS learned the family's priority is her
young children what do you tell your
twins about their grandfather I just
tell them that that you know he was a
very special
person and everybody loved him the
daughter of Elvis and Priscilla Presley
shared two kids with ex-husband Michael
Lockwood 14 year old twins Finley and
Harper Finley's Mommy's girl Harper's
Daddy's girl a source close to Michael
tells E.T he obtained full custody the
moment Lisa Marie died something goes
down Harper will want Daddy and if
something goes down with Finley she
wants me meanwhile Priscilla is doing
everything she can for her grandchildren
what do they call you Nona Nona as for
the twins they're spending all their
time with Michael and trying to keep it
as normal as possible without their
mother I mean that's what I focus on
most the time the girl's dad spent the
last six years fighting with Lisa Marie
for custody and in the wake of their
mother's death there could be a new
battle I think this is going to end up
in front of a judge if there is going to
be a dispute first husband Danny Keough
who was living with Lisa Marie and the
twins at the time of her death
reportedly considers himself their
stepfather he's got so much Integrity
he's also my best friend but our source
makes a point to note that nobody wants
Bad Blood right now I don't think that
there are any concerns at this time with
his physical fitness and well-being like
there were early on in the separation in
terms of physical custody it's probably
going to go to the biological father the
twins are now 14 years old they have
minds of their own they have preferences
in terms of where they want to go to
school who they want to live with and so
the court is definitely going to honor
that on Sunday Lisa Marie will be laid
to rest at Graceland alongside her
father and next to her son Benjamin who
died in 2020 is absolutely 100 of mine
always has been mine Graceland a rep for
Lisa Marie confirmed sweet tea Graceland
will go to all three children
Otis daughter Riley Keough and the twins
and when it's no longer mine it with my
children's you know that's that
[Music]